so Queen C5 that's stalemate
mating one all good so far second C5 and
give a check Take Back The Rook so far
the puzzles are with brute force and
then I can do them otherwise I cannot so
I go King C1 no say Square for the for
the bishop standard study stuff I've
seen this one rookie
is it from one of your games yeah wow
did you make the puzzle this is by the
way the head of streaming in the
background
also known as the hammer everybody knows
him some people love him
I like these ones take the queen take
the bishop
I feel like they got me some some easy
ones this time
you got the luck of the draw the
randomizer yeah exactly take this one
Queen E7 and queen D6 this is a nice
puzzle